So here is a representation of the restaurant script. Here is the name of
the script, restaurant, and the six elements that we talked about earlier.
Track, props, roles, entry, result and scenes. So
this particular track refers to formal dining. Here are the props, tables, menu,
check, money, food and place. And for food and place we can use symbols. These
symbols can be used as variables. So where I may different kinds of foods and
different kinds of places in a restaurant. Here are the rules, so
S is a customer, W is a waiter, C is a cook, M is a cashier, O is an owner and
so on. The entry conditions are S is hungry, S as the member is a customer,
S has money and those conditions are that S has less money. S is not hungry.
S is pleased. But O has more money. And scenes, well,
let's discuss them in the next slide. Here is a representation of scene one.
We'll call it the entering scene. This particular scene consists of
several events. So in the first frame, the customer S, S stands for
the customer. Moves himself or herself. So S is moving himself or
herself to some restaurant, some place P. And the second frame,
the agent S, the customer Sees some table. So this frame,
the customer S decides to, take an action. The particular action is, where this
agent S this customer S moves. Customer S himself or herself to the table.
So this is a walking action going on. Let us continue another set just a little
bit longer. So now S is moving his own body into a sitting position. Here,
the waiter sees the customer, and now the waiter moves himself to the customer.
And now the waiter moves the menu, to the customer. And
this completes a representation of the first scene of entering in a restaurant.
One can imagine many more scenes. The next scene might be a way to customer
orders food. The third thing might be the way the waiter brings food, and so
on and so forth. And then the last thing is the customer pays the bill and
then walks out. This is a stereotypical notion of a script.
Your notion of a script, might be slightly different depending on what kinds of
restaurants that you go to. In different cultures, the script for
going to a restaurant might be quite different. The point here is that
the script is capturing in a knowledge representation, what is known about
the stereotypical situation of going to a restaurant of a particular kind.